when we launched this show about 16
months ago this was the kind of story I
had in mind uh the Royal Kew Gardens are
set to hold an exhibition called queer
nature at the end of the month the event
promises to break the binary and
challenge traditional Expectations by
showing how fungi and plants have a
special connection to the lgbtq
community
queer nature to me is is basically a
very apt description of nature for me
queer nature is about rethinking how we
see the world around us and our place in
it viewing the world of nature as queer
is an act of freedom and liberation
well the event promises to bring
together horticulturalist scientists
authors and drag artists even featuring
a performance from a bearded lady in a
DJ who will play queer sets my question
for all this is why let's get into the
weeds of the debate without key Coast
Tommy lahren and the comedian James Barr
James welcome back sorry did you launch
this show with the idea of talking about
gay mushrooms yes that's why you
launched it I have some gay mushrooms
that you just wanted to do a segment
about queer mushrooms thank you for
taking up my gay mushroom wow they don't
look very gay well they look like normal
mushrooms well are you feeling a gay
connection to these muffins listen I
feel a gay connection to a lot of things
peers including yourself right now I am
I would say that mushrooms
scientifically have about 23 000
different genders so that's where this
exhibit exit bit is coming from 23 000
genders of mushrooms exactly it's just a
mushroom no we'll ask a scientist if you
don't believe me I'm not I've asked a
scientist this is called the mushroom
that's it but they're like they're fungi
other than sexual about mushrooms what
sex is not about mushrooms no so why are
we having some queer celebration of
things like mushrooms I just don't
understand why you care why is this such
a problem
where the entire month was taken up with
Tony everything lgbtq and now it's two
plus something else right it's extended
so letters I can't even remember the
rest of the year why does Kew Gardens
have to go queer I don't get it why
can't here why should it well because we
just have straight plants because I tell
you what it's doing it's making queer
people feel happy and ultimately isn't
something Society should just be about
changing everything so that you James
Barr get your kicks are looking at the
kinky mushroom listen you might want to
spend your life being miserable but I'll
tell you what really I'm very happy
yesterday you lost an NTA to a gay man
so you've decided to find any story you
can to attack queer people because you
want to get your hand program not hadn't
actually thought of that that's exactly
what's happening it is true it is not
bad it's entirely Graham Norton's
sexuality that enraged me let's bring in
uh Tommy I just don't know where we
start with this
cute Gardens is that the is that the
epicenter British Heritage The
Establishment it's like you go there
with your mum and dad you take your
cucumber sandwiches and you look at
lovely plants what you don't do is think
about their sexuality or 23 000 genders
or have a queer celebration of mushrooms
what is happening
well I'll tell you this what concerns me
is if there are 23 000 genders for
mushrooms and fungus I'm a little
concerned because the lgbtq plus
barbecue is already too long for most
Americans and most people to memorize so
now if we have 23 000 genders added to
that I'm not sure we want to take our
cue from Plants but you hit the nail on
the head Pierce why does everything have
to be about queer this gay that why is
that the only thing that leftists seem
to respond to it's either race gender or
climate change race gender climate
change that's it everything has to be
gay everybody
about the planet yeah there has been a
whole debate actually about whether
plants are racist I remember that one as
well the the thing about this it's
probably a debate that you had though
but the thing about this James is I just
I just don't see the point of it other
than to wind people up which I think
you're almost admitting no absolutely
not it's not whining anywhere Divine
Mouse tomorrow we're going to go down to
Chelsea sea flower show and we're going
to have a straight day where straight
people like me we'll go straight people
like me who by the way for the record
are not remotely homophobic right go
down to Chelsea flower show and we make
everything about the straight sexual
Affinity you did yourself
no that was obviously a joke you made a
stupid facile point about a sexuality
interesting but I don't care whether
he's gay or not I care that he beat me
that that pisses me off but let's go
back to the Chelsea flower show I've had
a straight day or a straight week of a
Chelsea voucher and started talking
about these straight heterosexual
affinancy that we all felt with fungi
and daffodils you would go completely
nuts and I said look at these white
straight Gammon abusing Us in this
manner excluding Us in this manner if
you and Tommy want to set up a straight
mushroom exhibit with loads of straight
gray boring binary mushrooms
I'm not doing it waving guns around like
go for it I'm not doing it it's it's
your community they're doing it listen
you're the one that's hosting a debate
on an international platform about
mushrooms yes gay mushrooms because the
event is happening
gay mushrooms
not a gay mushroom look you just eat it
what wow I hope you enjoyed they're not
poisonous you know you're not queer
because you can catch Queen it's from a
mushroom by the way so I mean
I just I think Tommy my overriding view
like you said everything has to be
reduced to this kind of stuff it is
pandering virtue signaling nonsense but
what worries me is that the corporate
world like Kew Gardens and their
management they get sucked into this
they think it's a good idea well as I
can imagine lots of people who attend
these events we're thinking what is
going on why are they doing this
yeah I think it's just out of step with
most most people I don't know why
everything has to be about sex sex and
sexual preference it doesn't make sense
to me I don't think most human beings go
about their day worried about the gender
of a mushroom or a fungus or what gender
they prefer to sleep with I don't know
why everything has to be reduced to this
can we all just go about our lives it
hasn't been until 2020 I believe that
everything had to be about how you
identify and what pronouns you use can't
everything just be as it is without
having to dissect the heterosexuality
their homosexuality or the queerness of
everything give everything some kind of
a queer rating so why do you totally
agree we're running out of time James
final question and make a quick answer
what is the gayest plan
everyone is every single person on this
planet has different uh different you're
not going to name it celebrate it's not
one that you think I guess a daffodils I
like a daffodil a gay daffodil all right
well on that bomb show we'll leave it
there Tommy thank you very much Dave for
joining me it's nuts we know it's nuts
but James will keep coming back to
defend the nuts and that's why I like
him